so what you have is four sets of columns
back here all of which have varying
degrees of damage when Delaware
discovered early this month the columns
of its 40-year old I 495 bridge we're
tilting the state move fast it
immediately shut down a roadway used by
ninety thousand vehicles a day within 10
days workers installed braces to support
the columns the bottom line is we got it
close to time no one was injured and now
we got to get it back open the emergency
repair costs two million dollars with 18
million more needed to finish the job
the federal Department of Transportation
is footing the bill we have projects all
over the state that depend on that
federal funding if that federal funding
dries up and those projects may have to
be stopped that's a real risk
confronting Delaware in the 49 other
states the federal highway trust fund
the nation's primary source for public
road projects has shrunk to eight
billion dollars it could be drained by
late august one reason for the shortfall
the federal gas tax which accounts for
seventy two percent of the Highway Trust
Fund has been stuck at eighteen cents a
gallon for regular fuels since 1993 this
is a national issue US Transportation
Secretary Anthony Foxx says unless
Congress acts quickly to fix the fund
States will suspend summer construction
plans we're expecting that by late June
maybe middle July some of the states
will already start to pull back projects
and slow other projects down and even
stop something that's because most
states get a majority of their
transportation funds from the federal do
t from a low of 35 percent in Utah to a
high of 98% in Rhode Island the trust
fund is not replenished the gridlock in
Washington is going to reach Main Street
America the i-495 bridge is one of six
hundred and seven thousand bridges in
the u.s. one out of nine or 67,000 are
rated structurally deficient by the
american society of civil engineers we
do have an infrastructure crisis I would
define it as an infrastructure deficit
it's been estimated in the trillions of
dollars and the problem is is that we
keep even when we're at our most
aggressive we're talking about trying to
just get the funding levels back to
where they were last year two senators
Democrat Chris Murphy from Connecticut
and republican bob corker from tennessee
are proposing to increase the gas tax by
12 cents over the next two years but
that idea won't be considered until
after
lawmakers move to keep the Highway Trust
Fund solvent this summer Phil Mattingly
Bloomberg News Washington